we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P here is a really good
question that many of you have written
in with about the telepathic
declassification of documents take a
listen
hey David enjoy show hey
right uh he's considering president you
can do that right have fun yeah no it's
I get that it's a joke but it's
absolutely a real thing
if Trump can think about documents and
declassify them then Biden can think
about documents and classify them and
thus it becomes completely
indefisible one way or the other because
no matter what at any point any document
could be classified or Declassified
based on what the current president has
thought about it's absurd these people
are nuts Guys these people the
telepathic declassification give you a
break it's pathetic we have a great
bonus show for you today Liz Cheney
Republican congresswoman Liz Cheney
outgoing because she was defeated in her
Republican primary in Wyoming Liz Cheney
says that if Trump is the nominee in
2024
she will leave the Republican Party
and she will campaign for Democrats
what yes we will discuss that on today's
bonus show secondly eighty percent of
American voters want Congress to enact
National paid family leave and this is
another one of these examples where we
supposedly have the will of the people
reflected in the elected officials that
are voted on by the pop the general
public and yet the general public is
very far to the left
of our elected officials and this is
another issue where that is the case and
thirdly everything going terribly for
Rudy Giuliani who has now been ordered
to pay his ex-wife 225 thousand dollars
or face jail time Rudy is claiming that
as a result of all of this legal trouble
in which he finds himself he doesn't
have the money he says he's uh
increasingly without money
is that even true we don't know we'll
talk about it and more on today's bonus
show you can sign up at joinpakman.com
to get instant access to the bonus show
we will see you then or otherwise right
back here tomorrow Michael Cohen
scheduled to join us later this week
about his new book I do want to hear
from him about some of these latest you
know what when the pictures came out of
Trump's Mar-A-Lago I thought Michael
Cohen would know what does Trump's
office normally look like is it normally
the mess that it appeared to be in the
pictures I have so many things to talk
to him about he has a super interesting
new book that'll be later this week but
for now sign up at joinpakman.com and
we'll see you back here on the podcast
tomorrow